ja
es ist mal wieder an der Zeit für
Schreiner to love mit Luca
für alle die denke ich fahre die ganze
Zeit Fahrrad wegen dem Klimawandel
nee fahr Fahrrad weil ich so fett bin
okay
[Musik]
also ich will jetzt nicht bei jedem
tiktok hier einfach okay sagen aber mir
fällt nichts anderes ein
[Musik]
versteht gar nichts mehr
als er und das ist ein bisschen Bruder
lass mich einfach in Ruhe
[Musik]
alles klar alles klar
fragt mich
ich will also keiner was ich habe
[Musik]
der hat ca 13 Red Bull auf einmal
getrunken
[Musik]
genauso kommt meine Freundin immer
reingelaufen wenn ich wieder irgendwas
ich habe keine Freundin
ich hoffe du verstehst das was ich von
dir wollte und was du von was ich von
nee doch was ich von nee
was du von nee
einer von uns ist du
was du
ist ja eigentlich ganz logisch weil ich
schon angegriffen
[Musik]
das ist Cybermobbing
no joke es ist for real so dumm dass man
bei einem Frühstücksbuffet in einem
Hotel sich erst einmal kurz hinsetzen
muss damit man weiß welchen Tisch macht
und dann erst losgegangen zeigt doch
einfach auf den Tisch und Ende
[Musik]
in etwa so haben die kantinenköche
unserer Mensa damals gekocht willkommen
bei der Berufsvorstellung von Firma Bus
wir haben hier ein Büro
da da und da und da hinten außerdem
haben wir eine Lampe Obst Zettel Pflanze
und eine Tür da gehe ich hier drauf
tschüss
das war's von Firma Boos
SOS ich bin überzeugt
das ist einfach amerikan ein Video ne
chinesische Nudeln
[Musik]
ich dachte vor real dass das normale ist
dass jeder Mensch so sieht
[Musik]
Gesundheit have in asking
jeden Tag
[Musik]
das hält no joke so crazy ne wenn du ein
kleines Kind bist kannst einfach sein
dass du irgendwas machen willst aber
dann wirst du hoch gehoben oder in
Kinderwagen gesetzt oder angestellt dann
geht's mit dir irgendwo anders hin
mein ganzes Leben war eine verdammte
lüge ich habe noch keine Schönheits-OPs
gemacht wenn ich bin ein ehrlicher
Mensch ich würde dazu stehen ich würde
sagen warum und wenn ich mir irgendwann
irgendwas lassen machen werde werdet ihr
die erste Seite die es erfahren ich habe
noch nichts machen lassen also alles gut
genau
[Musik]
exakt das ist die Definition davon was
Jungs machen wenn ihre Freundinnen
denken dass die Jungs Fremdgehen würden
oh das war richtiges Deutsch
[Musik]
warum soll ich das nicht oh ha junge
warum redet sie plötzlich wie ein Bär
warum
das hat ein kleiner Junge in Dortmund in
der Innenstadt live gesungen
sorry ich bin raus zum Ende zeige ich
euch allerdings noch mal ein Video von
zwei Mädels die gerade versuchen
auszupacken
viel Spaß und Ciao Stopp aber jetzt
[Musik]
darfst du nicht
okay komm Stopp
[Musik]
komm komm komm Stopp
okay ich glaube du kommst durch
[Musik]
ja komm komm komm geil Alter geil Alter
Prof